jonathan et jonathan surtout parce que
c'est vrai que ce que vous auriez pu
faire une émission de télé réalité ou
non jamais impossible impossible ouais
bah c'est pas mon délire pas mon délire
alors vous avez 13 prétendantes dans la
série ouais ça vous a fait quoi d'être
désiré par donc pas parce que à un
moment vous êtes dit c'est qu'il
m'arrive contient évidemment être jeudi
aux cérémonies des billets ouais c'était
tellement fou parce que tu les as quand
même face et là pour le coup je vais
dire un truc qu'on a tous vécu une
expérience de dingue c'est que on arrêt
on coupait pas les caméras y avait c'est
on est en tournée c'est on a tourné 50
minutes les trucs que tu vois deux sans
coupure sans rien donc on était vraiment
un moment donné en voilà en télé réalité
et on vivait le truc les instants il y
avait le pain le suspense y avait tout
et on était on l'a vraiment vécu de
l'intérieur
et c'est dingue à vivre vous êtes avec
vous avez une fiancée comment elle a
pris le truc ça va ça passe ça
franchement ça passe ça passait pas ces
crèmes c'est pas ta crème a fait passer
crème après elle connaît quant à elle
alors qu'il était à la maison tout cela
a eu aussi des vies d'al hader elle
adore kita d'orchidées alors y'a un truc
aussi que vous avez fait vous avez fait
quelque chose vous avez fait vous même
fait les pubs diffusées à la syrie oui
j'en attends tu taintrux ce qui est
dedans
cette fois ce n'est pas des parodies
regardez bien il sait vraiment ce sont
des vrais pu dans lesquelles il s'est
incrusté sommes fatigués d'avoir la
fatigue et c'est fatigant crème
hydratante hydra énergétique men expert
vous aident à combattre les signes de
fatigue montrez à votre peau vous
l'aimez femmes hydratant hydra
énergétique antifatigue 24 heures parce
que nous le valons bien
je ne connais pas encore téléchargé
notre api je sais que vous êtes un jeune
couple vous venez d'arriver mais moi je
suis seul et bientôt sans même s'il
continue à m'en fous
dix nouvelles bernard découvrez-les
hybrides rechargeables et sans
engagement et même sans engagement j'ai
réussi à m'accrocher dans cette lutte
[Applaudissements]